Hello world.
It's Saroj and welcome to my new
course titled Machine Learning Journey.
If you're a student or between
jobs or in a different field,
this 10 week course will help you learn
everything you need from marketing your
skills to learning the best tools to
building a solid mathematical foundation.
Two techniques to stay up to date on the
latest breakthroughs in order to get a
job or start your own venture.
As a machine learning
engineer or data scientist,
this course will be free and publicly
available on Youtube. I do this for you.
All I ask is for you to hit the subscribe
button to get notified when I release
new content.
In this video,
I'll show you how to write the perfect
resume for a machine learning or data
science position.
Sending in your resume is the universal
first step in landing an interview for a
position at any company.
Yes.
Eventually there will be more efficient
ways to assess candidates skills,
but for now we have to deal with the
art and science of resume writing.
I've gone through this process several
times for the companies I've worked for
as well as reviewed resumes for job
positions I've been recruiting for and the
amount of misinformation around this
resume writing process is what got me to
create this tutorial.
If we look at the data on resumes,
it's pretty surprising the
average interviewers spend
only six seconds scanning
a resume and usually interviewers won't
even look at your resume until you walk
into the room because the vast majority
of resumes are first screened by
automated systems.
58% of resumes have typos and 75% of all
resumes are automatically discarded by
the systems.
Clearly having a great resume is the
most important part in landing a machine
learning position and once you get that
down you can start focusing on other
more advanced tactics like
genetic modification to
help you stand out from the
masses.
Application tracking systems or ATS has
introduced a new gatekeeper to the job
search process.
These are automated filtering algorithms
that can rate resumes based on a few
factors.
So submitting a resume
that isn't optimized for an
ATS is the biggest mistake
you can make as a job.
Applicant also applying to Sarah knows
the reason companies use an ATS is
because an AI can scan millions of resumes
permanent and this card up to 80% of
them automatically,
which means the recruiter only has to
worry about the top 20% a massive time
saver. Historically recruiters would
have to read every single resume,
but AI allows them to scale in
a way they couldn't otherwise.
It's safe to assume any company you're
applying will very likely be using an
ATS.
When an AI has given a candidate resume,
its first step is to parse that
resume to find expected sections,
meaning it will be programmed to search
for information on your work experience,
your education, your skills, et cetera.
And while Ai is good at parsing,
it can't interpret slang just yet.
So if you title this section about
your work experience as previous gigs,
it'll likely ignore that
section completely since it
doesn't know what a Gig is.
What that means is you'll need to use
standard plain English resume sections,
the four major ones you should
list our work experience,
education skills and projects.
I've found that Novo resume.com is a
really helpful tool to generate a resume
template that works for you.
They've got a lot of options and it's
free as you're writing your resume.
A good thought experiment is to step
into your prospective employers shoes.
If you were them, what would you
be looking for in a candidate?
You can craft an elevator
pitch for yourself,
a short summary that describes your most
impressive accomplishments and use that
as a guide to help you write your resume
detailing those points even more in
just one page.
The ATS wants to match your resume with
certain keywords that are found in the
job description for that specific job.
So let's say for a given position,
we see this paragraph as
part of the job description.
We can pick out keywords from it that
sound important and use those in our
resume.
We can use the tool word clouds.com and
paste in the entire job description page
into the word list.
It'll spit out an image that showcases
every word in the job description letting
us use the most frequent ones
will come to the resistance.
When we start writing a resume,
it's beneficial to use bullet points
instead of paragraphs as those have been
shown to be beneficial for ATS
software while using a photo isn't.
It also might go without saying,
but definitely use the same
font throughout the resume.
I recommend sands,
Sarah,
and since employers don't have
much time to read resumes,
make sure to list your most
impressive accomplishments. First,
don't just try and list every single
thing you've done since high school like
lead hacking,
Nasa.
While chronological resume listings are
common when it comes to a cutting edge
field like machine learning skills and
experience matter more than history and
degrees, so that means put the
most impressive section first,
the most impressive experience first,
the most important bullet point first.
Each of your bullet points should be
ruthlessly concise as this reflects your
communication skills.
For example,
a bad bullet point would be training
and optimizing a support vector machine
learning model on a Dataset to predict
the quality of Avocados with an accuracy
of 98% a better bullet point would be
trained a support vector machine to
predict avocado quality with 98% quality.
This way we aren't reusing similar
words and we keep it simple.
These bullet points, it should
show, not tell numbers and metrics,
but you show the impact you can have
rather than relying on filler words.
Instead of saying you significantly
improved conversion rates,
say that you doubled conversion rates
from 0.5% to 1% the same rules applied for
past projects show.
Don't tell.
It's better to say you trained a neural
net on 10 k images to classify rubber
ducks. Then you gained extensive
experience with neural nets.
This makes you more memorable and acts
as an easy talking point during the in
person interview, and this applies
to academic coursework as well.
Since grading and naming conventions
vary from school to school.
Instead of saying you got an a in NLP,
say you wrote a Web crawler to scrape
and Parse text data for NLP algorithms.
When you're done writing your resume,
give it to a friend with no background
in machine learning to review.
They ideally should still be able to
identify your key credentials even if they
don't understand all the terms.
They'll also be able to tell you
if they see any grammatical errors,
liberal arts majors, we
love you. After that,
you can get a free resume review from
top resume.com from a resume expert to
double check your work when you're
ready to submit your resume.
Don't use a pdf as,
it's not very ATS friendly.
Use a word file or a plain text file
because it's much easier to parse.
And because job descriptions can vary
so much between companies for the same
position,
it's best if we make multiple copies of
our resume and tailor each of them to
whatever company we're applying to.
We can keep a master version of our resume
as a base and make spin offs from it.
Oh and a lot of the more advanced systems
can automatically scan for your other
social media profiles and use that data
as part of its decision making process.
So if there's anything
you want to keep private,
make sure to lock it down
with maximum privacy settings.
Sometimes you'll be asked to send
in a cover letter with your resume.
For this, I like to follow a
simple two paragraph format.
The first paragraph should tell the
company why you want to work for them.
Use a single specific
reason and elaborate on it.
The second paragraph should tell the
company why they should hire you.
Highlight the exact things you're going
to bring to the company and back it up
with a specific example.
So having a great resume is
key to getting an interview,
but get hub acts in many ways
has an unofficial resume,
especially in this field because it
doesn't just say the work you've done,
it showcases it for anyone to analyze.
Since it's open source,
it gives employers a clearer
idea of your technical skills.
Have at least two projects
here that you can showcase,
made sure the code works.
It's well documented in the read me
with both installation and how to run
instructions. Ideally you have an image
of the demo in the read me as well,
and of course a link to a web app version
so anyone can try it in the browser at
themselves.
There are a few great resources that I
recommend to help you further refine your
resume and I listed them all.
Video description,
ready to start applying.
I've got so many more tips if the
subscribe button to stay up to date on my
programming videos and for now
I've got to review some resumes,
so thanks for watching.